ich war gestern in führt den ganzen tag
wir haben gefeiert glücklich er hat ist
125 jahre alt geworden würde er noch
leben er ist der vater der sozialen
marktwirtschaft der vater hat
deutschlands wirtschaftswunder er hat
damals die spielregeln geschaffen mit
denen deutschland dann am ende des tages
ja so erfolgreich wurde und diese
spielregeln werden heute mit füßen
getreten aktuelles beispiel jetzt am
donnerstag in dieser woche im plenum
wird der jahreswirtschaftsbericht
besprochen und diskutiert von herrn
haare herr beck möchte gern die soziale
marktwirtschaft um modellieren sie
sollen in zukunft nicht mehr soziale
marktwirtschaft sondern soziale
ökologische marktwirtschaft heißen
ludwig erhard würde sich im grab
umdrehen weil er sagen würde die soziale
marktwirtschaft wenn man sich richtig
anwendet ist in sich ökologisch weil
wenn man die umwelt verschmutzt muss man
auch geld dafür bezahlen das ist das
sogenannte haftungsprinzip und ich mache
mir sorgen um diese soziale
marktwirtschaft weil mittlerweile immer
mehr parteien sich die soziale
marktwirtschaft zu eigen machen für
opportune zwecke selbst sahra
wagenknecht ist vor einigen jahren durch
deutschland gerannt und hat einen
vortrag gehalten unter dem titel
rückbesinnung auf nützlich ehrt das
macht mir sorgen das möchte ich
kann verstehen dass carsten linnemann
sie sorgen dafür dass sahra wagenknecht
die man nicht recht geht aber ich finde
man erstmal robert habeck zu verteidigen
eine ökologisch soziale marktwirtschaft
ist an sich kein schlechter gedanke ich
will nur mal darauf hinweisen dass die
wirtschaft ja selber drängt die
wirtschaft will co2 frei werden die
wirtschaft will nachhaltiger werden weil
sie das als geschäftsmodell sieht für
die zukunft mir macht er die politik
sorgen dass sie fast nicht mehr versteht
was ordnungspolitik früher einmal war
nämlich anreize zu schaffen anstatt
vorgaben zu machen planungen zu machen
anreize zu schaffen und dann eben
vielleicht die marktkräfte sich
entwickeln zu lassen das ist
diskreditiert worden und muss politik
muss man sagen von fast allen parteien
das macht mir sorgen aber eine
ökologisch nachhaltige volkswirtschaft
als geschäftsmodell deutschland und wir
brauchen ein neues geschäfts- und da
sind wir uns alle einig dass industrie
wunder kommt nicht mehr also ja nicht
alle werden die sich erst mit dem
argument man mit kohle und
gaskraftwerken und dem mittelstand der
nach jahre werden wir selbstverständlich
nicht die weltwirtschaft beeindrucken
können wir können das mit technologie
mit technologieoffenheit und sicherlich
auch mit nachhaltigen technologien aber
dann müssen wir da die richtigen akzente
setzt und damals mir bei der politik
sorgen aber nur des geschäfts 100 wird
deutschland brauchen definitiv also wir
befinden uns ja hier in einer custom hat
gesagt sozialen marktwirtschaft und in
einer marktwirtschaft ist es ganz
generell eigentlich so dass die firmen
selbst sehen selbst entdecken die
unternehmer die mitarbeiter selbst
entdecken wo gibt es eine neue trends wo
passiert das so passiert das wo muss ich
investieren darf der staat eigentlich
gar nicht vorgeben und wenn unternehmer
sagen haben ein interesse daran
uns nachhaltig aufzustellen dann ist es
auch jedem unternehmer freigestellt das
zu machen es hat niemand ihren mast
gezwungen ein auto herzustellen was
quasi mit batterie betrieben wird und
nicht mit diesel oder benzin wird hat
keiner gemacht hat ihnen mast
selbstständig gemacht auch übrigens bill
gates wurde ja auch nicht erzwungen
jetzt ein computer systemen hat er
selbst gemacht oder
barcelona sie werden dort wäre in
deutschland gescheitert elon musk wer an
tag eins gescheitert mit allen auflagen
die hätte erfüllen um an tag eins dieses
unternehmen sind das nein des risikos
planungssicherheit liefern und sie muss
eine ordnungspolitische struktur liefern
sich überhaupt gründen kann wie lange
das ist ein anderes problem aber das ist
darum nicht schwer aber da geht es darum
wird innovation verhindert als und
planung zu werden wenn es das haben die
unternehmen aber aber zu sagen ich mach
jetzt eine ökologische mannschaft werden
dass grünen parteiprogramme rein schaut
der sieht ja was damit gemeint ist damit
ist staatliche bevormundung um es ganz
plastisch zu machen etwas überspitzt
jetzt der bäcker der ökologische
brötchen backt er hat quasi anrecht auf
eine subvention der der sie nicht packt
hat kein anrecht auf eine subvention da
beginnt das problem wenn man einen co2
preis vorgibt wofür ich total bin dann
ist das in co2 preis und dann kann sich
am ende der bäcker selbst aussuchen ob
er mit dem alten diesel generator seine
brötchen backt oder ob er das mit
solarstrom macht beispielsweise das wenn
man sagt
hochwertiger weise sind in dieser strom
natürlich nicht machen deswegen der co2
preis ist eine lenkungswirkung ist eine
politische lenkungswirkung nur ein
effizientes instrument da wäre ich
sofort für und zwar dann aber bitte
nicht deutschlandweit sondern global
oder zumindest europäischen co2
zertifikatehandel für alle branchen das
hätte die grosse koalition durchgesetzt
können in europa hat sie leider nicht
gemacht es gibt sie nur für zwei branche
insofern ich bin für
marktwirtschaftliche instrumente sie
können aber trotzdem im ziel eine
ökologisch nachhaltige soziale
marktwirtschaft eric aber dann bitte im
ziel bitte die soziale marktwirtschaft
nicht kaputtmachen wenn sie sagen sozial
ökologisch und kann ich auch sagen lasst
uns auch sozial ökologisch nachhaltig
das ist doch ein sozialer
marktwirtschaft ist wie ein
fußballspieler gibt es einen ganz
starken schiedsrichter das ist der start
und dann gibt es spieler die müssen sich
an bedingungen halten und keine
bedingung ist das haftungsprinzip ja
walter eucken geht noch einen schritt
weiter ein ganz großer der sozialen
marktwirtschaft der sagt externe kosten
müssten übernommen werden müssen
internalisiert wenn das heißt der
autobauer ja der elenas wenn der eine
idee hat und baut eine fabrik dann muss
der wenn ihr die luft verschmutzt direkt
dafür was bezahlen das soziale
marktwirtschaft das haben wir seit
jahrzehnten nicht richtig gemacht aber
es war herrlich aber es ist ja das muss
man eigentlich sein muss nicht einigen
weil die lineare müssen spielregeln
einsatz in libyen ist ja wohl nicht die
regeln ändern müssen sich leider dann
auch entschuldigen sie haben ja in 16
jahren regiert und dass sie jetzt finde
ich wunderbar klimaschutz ist ein
allmende gut also müssen wir externe
effekte internalisieren und ich finde
das wunderbar ja das ist mal wieder
zusammenrücken aber das hätten sie
machen müssen wir hätten ein co2 preis
europaweit durch treiben sollen mit
allem was wir haben und das war weder
angela merkel noch anderen cdu
politikern offenbar so wichtig dass wir
jetzt diesen mischmasch an dem
verschwinden können da muss ich hin zu
stellen ja das kann man so was auf warum
haben sich darauf legen naja ich weiß
nicht nur wie von do co laufen möglichst
weltweit ich muss dem thema auch mal was
sagen und zwar es ist ja eigentlich mein
leben geredet haben wir die große
industriehalle aber letztendlich ist es
doch der mittelstand der eigentlich die
meisten steuern bezahlt und unsere
deutschland aufrecht erhält und gerade
der mittelstand hatte schwierig mit der
ökologie weil das was ökologisch machbar
ist ist einfach auch sehr teuer schon
alleine die genehmigungsverfahren wenn
man irgendetwas machen will muss man da
sein siegel hat und dann dieses siegel
das kostet dann auch wieder geld also
ökologisch zu sein für einen kleinen
betrieb das ist wirklich schwierig und
da gibt es wenig unterstützung vom staat
also viel zu wenig das ist das was ich
immer wieder höre und auch selber erlebt
und da sollte man doch schon mal
ansetzen dass man wirklich unseren
mittelstand unterstützt und sagt hier
steuersenkungen du und oder wenn du
ökologisch etwas machen willst dann hast
du hier in deiner deine unterstützung
und es geht ihm schon darüber dass man
ihm die betriebe dass man die gebäude
das man die in ökologisch saniert dass
die arbeitsmöglichkeiten in der richtung
dass es gefördert wird auch die
angestellten alles alles mögliche ist
schon alleine die herstellung von
lebensmitteln denn wenn das schon mal zu
st wer aber am ende doch in diesen staat
in diesem grünen bevormundung start der
punkt ist ja am ende es muss ein preis
geht man kann ganz ganz viel über den
preis regeln und wenn man sagt externe
effekte ist ja genau das richtige
stichwort das was du lieber unternehmer
treibst das ist relativ ein dreckiges
geschäft deswegen muss das was du
ausstößt an co2 stärker besteuert werden
und wird deswegen teurer das wird ihnen
automatisch dazu zwingen zu müssen der
reinen lehre dass er ein seine
produktion umstellen ja aber wenn er sie
und stellt dann muss es ihm auch
gefördert werden aber und nicht also
muss das gefördert werden das muss
gefördert werden weil es sagen warum
müssen sie ein unternehmer der viel
ausstößt warum müssen sie dem was zahlen
es ist ja gar nicht immer so dass die
sehr sehr viel ausstoßen wenn ich zum
beispiel an die lebensmittelindustrie
denke an an öko bauern und so viele öko
bauern die machen schon alles ökologisch
aber um ein öko siegel zu bekommen ist
das so viel strenger und dieses siegel
ist so teuer und
aber geht es nicht auch generell die
sehnsucht die rückkehr des starken
staates also ich habe das gefühl vor
allem seiner krone wie ein
brandbeschleuniger gewirkt für mich als
kommune die absolute staatsgläubigkeit
sehr viele deutsche bürger auch gezeigt
und meine frage ist ob nicht der starke
staat auch einfach gerade en vogue ist
also selbst auch kann er sein aber es
muss ja nicht richtig sein muss sind
kritisch sein und ich fand das beispiel
auch so toll noch mal zu sagen die
firmen die sage wollen nachhaltig
produzieren der größe frei
immer millionäre die sagen wir müssen
stärker besteuert werden jüngst wieder
nur leute es ist ja besteht ja nein doch
sie produziert sauber werden da sie
beide gleich und nicht nur der der sich
schon im rollstuhl dieser vergleich ist
geht doch nicht darum dass erstmal den
unternehmen vor geben will was sie
produzieren sollen oder wie sie arbeiten
soll ich sage co2 zertifikatehandel ist
bereits eine politische lenkungswirkung
das ist eine art förderung nämlich eine
zukunft in der wir möglichst gesunden
miteinander leben wollen die die
wirtschaft will das dii will aber
planungssicherheit die will eine ganz
klares effizientes system haben um diese
nachhaltige wirtschaft erreichen zu
können das ist dann trotzdem eine
politische lenkungswirkung also eine art
das in eine andere lenkungswirkung nein
ich rede über effiziente maria deswegen
die mit der mittelstellung sieht zu
korrigieren vorbild der mittel schon hat
keine angst vor ökologie der mittelstand
hat angst vor bürokratie das ist er aber
der ungar robert habeck vorhat der
beschränkt sich nicht auf den
lenkungswirkung durch einen co2 preist
das ist ja der trugschluss wir haben es
auch im wahlkampf erlebt da hieß es wir
machen co2 preis und dann sollten
trotzdem inlandsflüge verboten werden
oder noch mal extra preis bekommen also
entweder ich machen co2 preis und dann
geht dieser co2 preis für kerosin
beispielsweise inlandsflug auslands
flugstrecke kurzstrecke ist dann egal
dann muss sich das der verbraucher
selbst aussuchen da muss nicht noch mal
die politik kommen die gegend würde ja
dann auch teurer werden wenn man nicht
macht richtig viel los ist es aber dann
muss sie nun am boden nicht wo genau sie
aber dann kommt die grünen trotzdem noch
mal wieder auch in vorpommern haben und
sagen aber im inland darf nicht mehr
geflogen werden das passt nicht das ist
abgeräumt ist in schwerer weise soll
stehe ich dem programm aber das steckt
hinter einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft da steckt mehr dahinter
als einfach nur ein co2 preis denn den
man lieber michael brücker dingen gibt
schon länger den co2 wir aber der ist
viel zu niedrig oder jetzt nicht global
und erst in europa weiter so wie wir
jetzt nochmal hölle nennt man sie um das
letzte wort dürfen sie zu dem thema
haben weil sie jetzt gerade nicht so
weit gekommen sind ergänzt und am ende
ist die akzeptanz entscheidend wenn die
bürgerinnen und bürger sehen dass das
was wir hier klimapolitisch machen etwas
bringt dass entweder die welt uns nach
macht ja oder es bringt hier in
deutschland so viel dass wir die dinger
verkaufen umwelttechnologien dann packen
wir das wenn aber die welt sieht wie zb
in gütersloh da werden luftballons
verboten mit helium also am letzten
schultag darfst du städtischen
kindergarten nicht mehr diesen
luftballon in die luft gehen lassen im
weltklima gründen also ich kann mir
keinen präsidenten auf diesem globus
vorstellen der das nachmacht wir haben
ja so wie ein grab mit in der schule hat
die so jung noch vor jahren das war dann
heute
gehören zusammen so sprechen aber wissen
wenn ich solche maßnahmen mache ja da
muss mich nicht ärgern wenn das keiner
nachmachen 20 wundern wenn die
energiewende und klimawende nicht auf
akzeptanz stößt